[Music]
so i thought this is a surreal thing
that we have to watch okay
oh owen schroyer
oh my god i've been by the way we've
been on this gentleman's show yeah we've
been seeing uh i've been seeing this no
we've never been on his show oh i'm
sorry we we've been i'm not gonna give
him a pass until he lets us on his show
yeah we've been on his show while he's
filled we've been on him on alex's show
while he filled in for alex
um
so
as you know this ugly judge man of yeah
i know compared to the last one yeah so
they're trying to get um
to see how much 50 million dollars out
of alex's pockets right basically um and
uh
this is the judge getting well i'll just
show you
has he been anywhere but the beach yeah
he got well he's he's been outside a lot
of different rallies and [ __ ] so it
makes sense i mean he just looks
thoroughly sunburned like your brother
you need to take a day out you know
get skin cancer that you did a show and
then a
second show is that right yes
and
what were the topics of those two shows
i mean
were any of the topics of those two
shows this
this tribe yes
did you and mr jones talk about anything
that happened at the trial
i don't recall exactly what was
discussed
are they still available for viewing i
believe so
so you think you talked about the trial
without talking about what happened so
now they're saying that owen is talking
of the owen troyer in a show talked
about the trial
so alex can't defend himself at the
trial he doesn't get a jury trial by the
way they've already already decided he
was guilty
um and he's not allowed to even defend
himself
because now he also doesn't get his
first amendment anymore either right
he's not allowed to do anything they're
not allowed to talk about it so now she
brought owen on just to chastise him hey
[ __ ] you you stupid [ __ ] texas [ __ ]
how about that i'm so [ __ ] sick of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] regardless of
whether you well you whether you think
what alex did was was gross or not you
have every right to believe it was right
but
you're still allowed to be wrong on the
internet
i'm sorry but you are
this is a very easy fix ready uh royce
ask me what i think about alex jones
what do you think about alex jones you
know i think frankly all that
misinformation he spread about sandy
hook and what he did to his parents is
[ __ ] disgusting and i could just
never support him and i'd never buy any
of his products and uh i personally
won't have him in my home you're right
he should go to jail
no no no sure he goes to jail wait
that's not what i said though
you said he's a terrible person
terrible people go to jail
they don't actually try and large okay
well
terrible people went to jail then
there'd be no people to man the jails if
payroll people went to jail alex jones
wouldn't be here because he wouldn't
have a show because there'd be no
terrible people to talk about shit's
good point
there's no more pedophile islands god
damn it they locked up the bankers in
2008. i got nothing to be angry about
harrison pull up a brendan shot video he
just starts doing commentary videos on
comics now
it just cured pediatric cancer
he's just like there's nothing left to
imagine alex jones doing a show where
all he reads is good news it'd be
amazing i would watch it yeah
oh my god we're colonized mars
we got water up there dammit
he's just screaming about it all happy
yeah sorry this judge is chastising
people
at the trial
inform you that you were under the rule
so is that a note did he have a
conversation with you about being under
the rule i'm sorry but pause
so it's his responsibility
it's the defendant it's the defendant's
responsibility
to tell
other people around him that they're not
allowed that's not how is that even fair
that doesn't even work though yeah i'll
be honest with you yeah between the
summary judgment
and between the way this judge is
needling them
there might be grounds for an appeal
here i'm not saying it would be
successful yeah but if i'm alex i want
to take this i want to take this trial
to every court that'll have it like when
we had him on i i'm sure you the same
thing like i didn't purposely ask him
about the trial on purpose because i
know he probably wasn't going to allow
to talk about that him specifically
right so i'm like i'm not even you know
whatever
uh because the last thing i want to do
is [ __ ] get him in trouble you know
plus we don't have alex jones on to get
gotchas no of course we're usually like
no come on we don't really do that with
anyone on this show we always bring them
on and go just come on and hang dude
except that harrison smith guy i'm
getting him on harrison smith on again
to call him a
weeb you'll see
you know what we're doing a whole expose
let's get harrison smith on next week we
are you know what harrison we're gonna
get him down we're dressing you down
buddy
i've seen all the [ __ ] anime you
watch bud did you know that you weren't
supposed to talk about it harrison yeah
mr smith if that is your real name
uh uh uh mr smith i must ask uh do you
have any aliases and he's like
on it uh
then i'd like to uh directly report to
this document here uh in which he's
referred to as gusto montgomery
[Laughter]
which one is it gusto
um
i don't believe so did he not tell you
you weren't supposed to discuss anything
that happened in this book did you tell
him i'm sorry is owen also not allowed
so because he because his boss is in
trouble owen's not allowed
to talk about it i'm sorry i feel like
this is a [ __ ] kangaroo court right
did he tell you that uh you're supposed
to wash your hands when you go to the
bathroom no i'm an adult i would be
weird if you tell you not to get in the
pool if you've just eaten after a half
hour ma'am i'm 35 years old you're
trying to get a cramp
no ma'am move to strike strike what
there's no judges here there's there's
no lawyers here it's just you what do
you want from me
why am i here
no honestly if i'm if i'm going at this
point i'm like what am i even doing here
oh it's like between this and january 6
man i just won't go home yeah seriously
[ __ ] leave me alone
any further questions
on this topic only
any other questions in this topic
and be careful
be careful because i you know [ __ ] you i
do whatever i want
i believe so and what time were you on
6 pm
and did you discuss any
witness testimony from the day or hear
anything about
any of the evidence presented
in
no i don't believe so
have you had any other show appearances
this week with mr jones
i
posted on one day and tuesday and i
believe that's it so you weren't on the
show yesterday yeah okay are you on the
show today
all right and these are all available
online right yes
uh yeah and by the way not from lack of
you guys trying to make sure they're not
can we start with that these are all
available online i don't know man only
because they're paying for this service
and by the way what if it's not
available online what if the [ __ ]
tomorrow what if tomorrow they decide on
their [ __ ] website they want to
delete an episode because the problem is
is that you can't just keep adding stuff
future stuff into this trial and saying
you're not allowed to delete that either
and anything you say in the future
you're also not allowed to delete and
you're never allowed to [ __ ] do
anything ever again all you could
[ __ ] do is what we tell you to do
because we're gonna put because our
system is so [ __ ] up that school
shootings happen we're gonna put it on
one guy who had a theory out there
because that's all we have these are the
people that are getting [ __ ] alex
jones is the guy that's getting in
trouble for this [ __ ] all right not the
[ __ ] pharma companies that are
[ __ ] making kids do this [ __ ] and not
the terrible school teachers that are
molesting these kids in the school
shootings not them not [ __ ] them
though ah the the guy who all of you
said is crazy who's basically the
national enquirer but now the sudden
what he's saying is super serious
[ __ ] hate this is such a [ __ ] joke
that's it but that's what i've been
saying from day one this whole trial has
made it like to where the way they
presented you'd almost think that alex
jones shot all those kids i know and
that's exactly right
like you're like i don't know sandy hook
something alex jones i think he shot a
bunch of kids i don't know how is that
man allowed to even be in public by the
way again this isn't this isn't whether
again this isn't whether you think what
he said was dumb i'm not even talking
about that
but should this guy be financially
responsible for his freedom of should be
held financially liable because it's
freedom of speech a defamation by the
way which a jury didn't even [ __ ]
decide this this [ __ ] fat [ __ ] judge
decided
jesus [ __ ] christ everybody's his
[ __ ] everybody wants to be a
vigilante warrior you know
all of these people look at what he did
was gross i can't believe it and even
though you know
we're only going to go after him now
because we need we need to make sure
that youtube and twitter and all these
places were justified and their reason
for kicking them off
by the way
which one was this what was the sandy
hook thing when did he say it was it
2000
let's see here
2012.
so 10 years ago
but now we're gonna come back to it
whatever
um